♪ Me and Gary Vee up in the office ♪
- [Man] What's cooking?
- It's my last week at VaynerMedia.
- [Man] I'm aware.
- It's crazy, I know, I've
been here three years.
- What are you doing?
- So, I'm going through
a very big life change
and I am leaving advertising,
leaving New York City,
leaving the country.
I'm just going to go
travel for like a year.
- Good for you.
- I wanted to do it for a
really really long time and--
- The sooner the better
with shit like that.
- I know, and I want to go into like
the health and wellness, medicine world.
- You look good.
- Thanks.
Yeah, I've been uh,
I definitely feel better than I used to.
That's for sure.
So, yeah, it's a big career
change you can't make overnight.
So, I was like, well, I might as well
take advantage of the
time and really like,
get some clarity and think about things
a little bit, because you can't make
big decisions like that when
you're so in the thick of it.
- In it.
- You're like, "I have no perspective,
I can't see anything".
- So right.
- So yeah, I mean, I feel like there was
so many factors that kind
of played a role and--
- Of course.
- But I don't know, the
past couple of months like,
all the cards kind of lined up perfectly
and I was just like, "This is right."
- Good for you.
- So, yeah.
- Thank you for everything.
- Thank you, I mean it's
been an awesome three years.
Like, I mean I told Shirley this
and I'll tell Claud this later,
at the end of the day I really do.
I leave with a lot of good vibes
and I felt very, just
like loved and supported,
and you don't find that
at a lot of agencies,
or a lot of places in general.
Yeah, it's been a great experience,
I'm super grateful for
it, it's weird to leave.
- Is there anything I can help
with in this next chapter?
- Probably, at some point for sure.
- Yeah, don't be shy.
- No, I won't, trust me, I won't.
- I believe you.
- I'll definitely like--
- I know what makes you good.
- If I can think about anything,
I think I need to kind of figure out--
- What?
- That world I want to go into is so huge
and it's getting really cluttered,
and it's getting really,
just like inauthentic.
- Can I give you a quick piece of advice?
- Please.
- Every world is like that.
- Yeah.
- Don't let that cripple you.
- And go narrow to what makes you pop.
- Right.
- Motivational speakers are
my most hated people, yet--
- You mean by other people?
- I hate them.
- Oh.
- Yet I get categorized in
that world all the time.
- Right.
- But I'm not crippled because I know
that I'm not trying to do the wrong thing.
- Right, or you're not
trying to do whatever.
- The wrong thing.
- Yeah.
- This is, forget about that.
- If you don't ever look
for the white space.
It doesn't exist.
- Hm, yeah, just like make it be your own.
- Do what the fuck you know.
- What you're good at.
- Like if you know yoga.
- Right.
- Yoga's plenty fucking
(mumbles), you know.
- Yeah.
- Be in the cream rises
to the top business.
- Yeah.
- Not in the I'm going to see
something no one else sees business.
- Right, and that's not the way.
I don't want to look at this as like
a business opportunity, of like,
let me go travel the world and
find these trendy things and bring them.
Like that's not what I, I truly want
to find a way to like, help people who are
chronically ill, and cannot feed...
They don't have the resources,
or something like that.
I'm not sure exactly what it is but--
- So, all the people that are doing
the wrong thing, crowded, not authentic,
it just has nothing to do with you.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I'm not crippled by other agencies
sucking up, giving a fuck about people.
- Yeah and if you were, you wouldn't
be where you are, because you can't--
- That's the thing you need to do.
- Yeah, that's a good piece of advice.
- It's a really good
piece of advice, like--
- Yeah.
- What do you want to do?
And do it.
And literally eliminate every other--
- That's actually really simple
when you think about it, like--
- It's super fucking simple.
- We get so in our heads--
- 'Cause we get taught, we get taught.
- Yeah.
- We get taught, and I think in hindsight,
my inability to learn that way--
- Mhm.
- Became my greatest strength.
- Yeah, and I feel like, but once you
learn that way, it's very
hard to unlearn that.
- It's very hard, the same way
I can't do the other thing,
I can't learn anything the normal way.
- Yeah.
- You know?
- Yeah, well a lot of people are like
"You know, what you're
doing it's kind of risky,"
and I'm like, I don't know--
- Risky for what?
- I just don't believe
in this whole notion
of like, okay you graduate, and you work
then get married, have kids and--
- You can pick up back from, come back
and work here, you're in the same spot.
- Yeah, I also just don't think--
- I actually think it's,
the other way is risky.
- Me too, because I think it's really
easy to become complacent, and--
- 100%!
- I don't know, I don't think it's
deviating from a path because I don't
think that there is a path.
- There's way too much respect for
anybody who thinks what
you're doing is risky.
- Yeah, I mean I've literally gotten
that response from like one person
but my family is like, "Yes, 100%, go"
- That's awesome.
- And they're so supportive.
- And the person that's,
you know, saying that,
is you know, respects a certain narrative
and that's awesome too.
- Right, and that's great for them.
- And may be great for them forever.
- Right.
- May be.
- Right, but yeah I've always been
pushed and questioned a little bit,
- Yeah.
- So I knew that this was going to happen
at some point, it was
just a matter of when.
- Well, I'm happy to help when
you get through the process.
- Thank you, yeah, I will definitely
hit you up on that at some point,
when I have kind of like, some clarity
about life, and when I'm back.
If I come back, who knows.
- Okay. Where you going?
- Well I was going to do South America,
but I just changed to now I'm going
to do Asia, because I want to spend
some time in India and do, like Chinese,
like ancient, Ayurvedic
medicine and study that,
and probably spend some time in
Indonesia too, and Napal, like farming.
- That's cool.
- It just is a place that aligns more
with like, my personal interests
than other parts of the world, so...
- I love it.
- Yeah, so I'll leave
for Vietnam in March.
- Amazing.
- Which is fine because--
- What are you going to do in February?
Just kinda--
- I'm going home, to Oklahoma
to just like, be with my parents.
- That's amazing.
- I don't ever see them
so, thank you so much.
- Thank you for everything, really.
- No really, you too.
- I mean it, ping me if you need me.
(smooth music)